Gregory: Three times a week,
I wake up really early
and leave Paris.
I kept it secret,
because people might
think I'm crazy.
Even my family didn't know.
It's like leading
a double life.
We are going to an island,
where I have a farm.
[gentle music]
I started with nothing.
It was really difficult to make
the field harvestable.
You just have to be humble
in front of natural
elements.
When I grew
my first organic potatoes,
I was so happy.
I was worried
about the world
we're going
to leave to children.
If they want to be healthy,
if they want to grow,
they need to have healthy food.
And after seven years,
we provide more than 500
schools and daycares in Paris.
This is my contribution,
to prepare the future
generation to change the world.